bonjour à tous aujourd'hui m'a parlé de
la conférence des développeurs d'apple
l'a d'abord linda value d'ici qui aura
lieu très bientôt le 4 juin prochain
lorsque entendant cette vidéo c'est
qu'on a regardé
quel pourrait être le contenu de la
conférence des développeurs d'apple à
quoi on devrait s'attendre d'un point de
vue software d'un point de vue hardware
et ça on va le regarder maintenant
tous les ans un peu le mois de juin nous
concocte sa conférence des développeurs
la d'abeilles ou d'abeille ou dc apple
worldwide developers conference cette
année tout débutera le 4 juin avec la
keynote de tim cook qui lancera cette
grande conférence pour tous les
développeurs qui travaillent dans
l'écosystème apple pour assister à la
kinnock le mieux c'est de vous connecter
sur internet le 4 juin 2010 8 à 18
heures heure française
pour tout savoir en direct si vous
souhaitez vous pouvez carrément aller au
mc enroe icône fashion center à san jose
aux états unis il faut faire la demande
pour vous enregistrer sur le site de
développeurs d'apple
attention hein c'est un tirage au sort
et le ticket d'entrée n'est pas cadeau
cadeaux ça vous coûtera 1000 599 $
america pour pouvoir y aller
et de toute façon il faut être membre du
programme de développeurs d'apple donc
ce n'est pas forcément ouvert à tout le
monde tous les ans on retrouve de
keynote d'apple la première au modjo
effectivement le diable ou de volume
d'ici qu'est la conférence des
développeurs et la quina du mois de
septembre où apple présente ses
nouveautés grand public et notamment les
iphone cette année où david avait lui
dit si on devrait avoir pas mal de
choses assez intéressantes d'un point de
vue logiciel et d'un point de vue
matériel
on va commencer tout de suite par le
côté logiciel et après on se posera la
question du point de vue matériel
avant toute chose je vous arrête tout de
suite arrêter la vidéo et dites moi vous
ce que vous penser qu'apple va pouvoir
annoncer qu est ce qu on va retrouver
cette année comme annonce principal au
début udev eu lieu dit si vous mettez
pause vous me le marquer et après vous
mettez lecture allez-y alors on y va
d'un point de vue logiciel on doit
pouvoir retrouver cette année alors j'ai
mes doutes vous inquiétez pas je suis en
train de lire ma note je bouquine pas
autre chose on va pouvoir retrouver
cette année l annonce de mac os 10
points 14
eyeos 10.12 watchou s5 tivio s12 des
nouveautés aussi concernant cyril
intelligence artificielle d'apple des
intelligences artificielles qui devenir
toujours plus intelligente avec le
machine learning sont des ordinateurs
qui apprennent et qui interagissent
encore mieux avec vous et avec
l'ensemble de la population
eyeos vous devrait vraiment mettre
l'accent sur la stabilité et la sécurité
avant de proposer de nouvelles
fonctionnalités c'est vraiment le point
d'orgue qui est donnée par rappeur
casser le pandore qui devrait être
donnée par apple cette année sécurité
stabilité
l'idée c'est effectivement de rassurer
les consommateurs notamment après tous
les problèmes
obsolescence programmée tout les
problèmes liés à la sécurité apple
aurait prévu de redessiner son os de
proposer un os vraiment réinventer ça
fait onze ans que ios n'a pas changé a
priori ça serait reportée à l'année
prochaine
non loin devrait aussi y avoir une
amélioration des os pour ipad avec
notamment une navigation par onglets
mais ça aussi ça serait reportée à
l'année prochaine devrait y avoir plus
de convergences avec d'un côté loes pour
mac et de l'autre côté à ios pour iphone
et ipad c'est désormais nos projets
marzi pan mardi panne je sais pas
comment vous allez prononcer c'est un
projet intéressant qui permettrait aux
développeurs de coder la même chose que
ce soit pour une application qui
tournerait sous mac os ou une
application sous ios l'idée si vous
voulez dans l'absolu c'est d'unifier
l'environnement mac os et ios
on va très bien qu'aujourd'hui les
smartphones sont plus en plus puissants
et deviennent des petits ordinateurs
alors ça dépend effectivement des
ressources dont vous avez besoin ça
dépend si vous allez faire du montage en
4k en 8k et je ne sais quoi encore mais
l'idée s'est pas réellement ça l'idée si
vous voulez c'est que votre smartphone
devient le centre de votre vie numérique
qu'on puisse se passer d'ordinateur à la
maison que vous n'ayez qu'à brancher
votre smartphone et qui ne vous servent
d'ordinateurs l'unité centrale
c'est ce que propose samsung avec le
decs c'est ce qu'a montré aussi razer
aux crs avec le projet linda il ya plein
de projets qui vont dans ce sens donc ça
c'est vraiment quelque chose qui est
super intéressant est à mon sens c'est
l'avenir des ordinateurs à la maison je
vois pas d'ordinateurs professionnels
avec des usages professionnels
mais l'ordinateur vous trouverez chez
vous votre smartphone deviendra vraiment
le coeur de votre bécane est ce qui fait
que vous aurez autant de smartphones
chez vous que vous aurez en réalité
d'ordinateur vous auriez donc un écran
un clavier une souris pourquoi pas ou
alors carrément imaginer que vos
smartphones nous servent de trackpad
ça peut aussi être un exemple et chacun
puisse branché sur smartphone dessus
avec une session qui lui sera propre
l'idée aussi c'est qu'effectivement il
ya une meilleure convergence entre les
différents os qui est le meilleur
communication en ami c'est vraiment là
dessus que travail apple au niveau des
eaux est sombre aussi un contrôle
parental qui serait améliorée une
application santé toujours plus
développée et toujours plus pertinente
pour allait fonctionner avec votre watch
il faut vraiment avoir conscience de la
santé collecter c'est quelque chose qui
va énormément se développer dans les
années à venir
la watch parce qu'elle est au plus près
de vous d'ailleurs famille la vie
d'aujourd'hui avec des capteurs toujours
plus précis
ils vont vraiment faire ce qu'on appelle
de la médecine prédictive c'est-à-dire
être capable de diagnostiquer des
problèmes avant même qu'ils aient
apparus ou en tout cas qu'il eut des
effets délétères
c'est vraiment là dessus que travail
apple et tous les gens du numérique il
devrait aussi y voir des animaux ji
redessiné et intégrée à l'ipad alors
l'ipad puisque je vous en parle vous
parler maintenant du côté matériel du
côté hardware parce qu'il devrait y
avoir aussi quelques annonces du côté
matériel même si effectivement c'est une
conférence qui est plutôt tournée vers
les développeurs donc de faire tous les
os faire tout ce qui est software
néanmoins on l'a vu l'année dernière il
ya eu beaucoup d'annoncés hardware cette
année il devrait y en avoir quelques
jeux aussi et des annonces assez
intéressante et notamment l'ipad
il devrait y avoir un ipad pro
redessiner qui ressemblerait fortement à
l'iphone 10 un écran bord à bord une
caméra route d'aix un écran peut-être
pas oled peut-être encore regardé du lcd
cette année nantua quelque chose de
vraiment redessiné et de beaucoup plus
sexy
d'ailleurs vous ai fait une vidéo pour
vous en parler pour les abordent lé
juste ici je vais aussi avoir un mac
book air entièrement redessiné avec un
écran retina avec plein de nouvelles
fonctionnalités dedans mais ça vous en
parler en détail un peu plus tard c'est
aussi ça mérite une vidéo à part entière
il pourrait aussi y avoir l'annoncé d'un
nouvel obs et oui le home pote d'alors à
laquelle fait la vidéo n'est toujours
pas arrivée en france il est arrivé aux
états unis en australie en angleterre
mais en france si on veut il faut
l'importer
no - vous arriver assez rapidement et
d'ici à ce que la conférence ait lieu il
devrait pouvoir être dans les foyers
français en tout cas dans ceux qui ont
souhaité le commander l'idée là
effectivement la pulse et proposer un
nouvel homme pod plus petit plus compact
et beaucoup moins cher l'idée
effectivement c'est de faire concurrence
à tout 105 connectés et notamment à
google com
il doit aussi y avoir une nouveauté pour
la tombe d'un moment c'est le mac pro
un nouveau mac complètement repenser
complètement redessiné réinventer pour
le cool c'est une annonce qui avait été
faite par apple en off à certains
journalistes 1 l'année dernière la
création du mac pro une nouvelle machine
plus puissante avec un design
complètement réinventé qui devrait un
peu bousculé les codes et proposer une
innovation une vraie innovation quelque
chose qu'on attend depuis longtemps chez
apple
alors quid de l'iphone se2
j'en avais déjà parlé dans une
précédente vidéo occasions existent ici
je vous invite à aller la visionner
l'iphone s2 pour être une évolution de
l'iphone est ce sa taille verrez un
iphone 10 low cost avec un écran lcd une
encoche en haut avec une caméra trop
d'eps personnellement je ne crois pas
particulièrement à ça je pense
effectivement qu'on devrait avoir un
iphone et se booster avec la puissance
d'un iphone 7 à l'intérieur plein de
nouvelles fonctionnalités un produit
super sympa super sexy plus puissants
toujours pas cher un nouveau produit
dans la gamme a priori ne serait
peut-être pas annoncé au début 2010 si
on prend toujours des pincettes on parle
de rumeurs il n'y a pas de choses
avérées il se pourrait qu'elle soit
annoncée à ce moment là ou alors est ce
que apple va faire le choix d'attendre
plus tôt le mois de septembre pour le
présenter avec l'ensemble des produits
parce qu'a priori cette année il y
aurait plusieurs iphone qui arriverait
au catalogue d'apple et ça justement je
vous en ai aussi parlé dans cette vidéo
alors je sais ça fait beaucoup de
contenu à les voir même du thé
complémentaires et c'est super
intéressant
bon un peu pour ce qui pourrait arriver
aux débats du début d'ici 2018 du point
de vue software du point de vue hardware
dites moi vous ce que vous en pensez
qu'est ce que vous attendez qu est ce
que vous pensez qu apple va présenter
cette année
et surtout qu'est ce qui vous ferait
vraiment tripé qu'est ce qui vous ferait
rêver
est ce qu'il ya un produit vous attendez
plus que l'autre est ce que vous êtes
plus du côté de l'ipad de l'iphone est
ce que vous êtes plus du côté des mac
air macbook mark et moi tout ça je pense
que c'est vraiment ce jeu super
intéressant et puis autre point
intéressant dites moi ce que vous
attendriez en termes de fonctionnalités
pour eyeos 12
j'ai hâte de lire vos commentaires et
bien sûr de pouvoir y répondre merci à
vous d'avoir gagné cette vidéo comme
d'habitude vous invite à laisser des
jolies pousse à rester connectés à vous
abonner et activer la cloche parce que
on va parler toujours plus de
technologies que ce soit apple samsung
huawei et tous les autres pas forcément
que sur la téléphonie
ça peut aussi être de leurs robotique a
plein de sujets passionnants donc rester
connectés et en tout cas on va parler de
plein de choses hyper cool merci à vous
d'avoir regardé cette vidéo je vous dis
à très bientôt soyez sages portez vous
bien et d'issia retrouvé des bijoux
[Musique]